[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory the
current world climate had me thinking
what sort of diseases and epidemics do
the witches and wizards of the magical
world face in this video we'll be
covering all of the elements that affect
humanoid witches and wizards black cat
flu black cat flu was an infectious
disease presumably from the same family
as influenza it was spread by black cats
and in 1996 there was an outbreak the
black cat flu epidemic is mentioned in
the daily profit in the film adaptation
of Harry Potter and the order of the
Phoenix blood malediction blood
malediction comes from a curse that
continues to resurface in her victims
descendants the curse can cause
different things in different people but
normally causes bodily dysfunction and
debilitation a story a Greengrass later
a story of Malfoy suffered from this
condition as the curse was placed on one
of her ancestors the condition made her
very frail Nagini
was also maledictis one who suffers from
malediction and her blood curse
eventually meant that she would
permanently transform into a snake a
spatter growth and Sarah broomis spatter
coit hepatic Roy is a highly contagious
Wizarding disease caused by an
infectious fungus it causes the
sufferers skin to break out in pus see
purple bumps once they've healed
blisters form which leaves scars if the
condition reaches the uvula of the
infected they aren't able to speak Sara
broomis patek roit is a particularly
violent substrain of the same fungus in
addition to the aforementioned side
effects it also causes confusion and
memory loss
there was speculated to have been an
outbreak in 1877 but no one can remember
dragon pox dragon pox is a contagious
disease occurring in wizards and witches
they can be fatal
it is similar in nature to the muggle
chicken pox it leaves little pock marks
on the skin and can result in a lasting
greenish tinge in some cases it can
result in a green and purple rash
between the
and sparks that come out of nostrils
when the patient sneezes greenthumb
this is a play on the muggle expression
greenthumb
which refers to someone who is
exceptionally killed at gardening the
Wizarding version is more literal and
refers to someone whose thumbs become
green and warty levitation sickness
levitation sickness is caused by a
levitation and results in an impairment
affecting the vestibular system that
affects the sufferers sense of movement
losers Logie losers lurchy is an illness
first mentioned by luna lovegood it is
unconformity is actually a disease but
by love goods definition we can infer
that it causes poor performance in
whatever activity they're doing like
Anthropy lycanthropy involves a
lycanthrope also known as someone who
transforms into a werewolf sometimes
they do it purposely but other times is
just a result of a curse there is no
cure for lycanthropy and people deeply
fear this condition as it can result in
a cursed existence mumble bumps mumble
bumps are a Wizarding disease that
caused a couple of side effects the
first side effect is a swollen neck and
face and the second side effect causes
you to constantly mumble it's treated by
lots of rest obscurus an obscure is
someone who carries an obscurus which is
a dark manifestation of repressed energy
they are parasitic in nature in that
they are deeply attached to the host and
obscurus is created when a child
consciously attempts to repress their
magical abilities or were forced to do
so through physical or psychological
abuse we see this in Creedence in the
fantastic beast films portkey sickness
portkey sickness is fairly
straightforward and is caused by
traveling with a portkey it's similar to
motion sickness and usually causes
hysterics and some nausea it doesn't
always happen and it only affects some
people sardine hex a sardine hex is just
what it sounds like and causes the
sufferer to sneeze sardines it's similar
in nature to the slug vomiting charm and
Hagrid was once on the receiving end of
it slug vomiting charm the slug vomiting
charm causes the sufferer to vomit slugs
you may remember Ron trying to
smile for with this only to have it
backfire on him because of his broken
wand scrofulous scrofulous is a
contagious visiting illness caused by an
unknown magical bug there is actually a
magical bugs ward at st. Mungo's
hospital that treats this disease
splintering splintering occurs when a
witch or wizard operates or dissipates
and successfully this leaves part of
their clothes or body in the previous
location the severity of sponging
greatly varies and can range from the
loss of a sock to the loss of flesh
stink itis stinky tiss is a smelly
magical disease that's caused by
inhaling the nauseous green gas from an
exploded stink pellet in 1979 there were
500 reported cases in London caused by
Caractacus Phelps who dropped 800 stink
pellets from the roof the daily profit
Umbridge itis Ambridge itest was a
Wizarding illness the students suffer
from in the 95 to 96 school year at
Hogwarts during an Bridges tyrannical
rule as headmaster the students bought
skiving snack boxes from Fred and George
Weasley which induced temporary illness
symptoms included fainting vomiting
fevers and even blood spurting out of
the nostrils vanishing sickness
vanishing sickness is an illness that
causes body parts to disappear like
scrofulous it was caused by an unknown
magical buck and that's all for this
video if you enjoyed it please drop a
like down below and if I miss any please
flag them with me in the comment section
like I said at the beginning I was only
mentioning the ailments that affect
humanoids until next time you're a
wizard Harry
[Music]